warning the following is what you should
not do during a zombie apocalypse viewer
discretion is advised
yes it's black summer everyone
coincidentally the same name is my high
school emo band I had really been
looking forward to the show considering
the way the Walking Dead is gone but
before you go and automatically dislike
this video era like book things store
you just don't understand the
complexities of a znation spin-off hear
me out let me in your car and we can
talk about it No okay fine I'll start
with something I liked about the show
[Music]
yes I thought the way they told the
pilot kicked ass
not only from multiple perspectives on
the same day in same event but because
it was told out of order and we don't
know what the hell is actually going on
it created both the sense of mystery and
unease an unease that correlated with
what the characters were going through I
wanted to keep watching to find out how
our characters got in certain situations
and what events forced them to come
together and it was cool to see a
segment that almost completely focuses
on the point of view of a zombie I had
high hopes for the series thinking that
if they could sustain this method of
storytelling for an entire season I'd be
hooked but after the pilot it's pretty
much downhill from there I can't help
but think how awesome the show would
have been if we saw different character
perspectives from different points in
time that later become interconnected
and give us better insights into the
world into the characters how cool would
it be if we the audience didn't know
that one or more of the storylines were
happening let's say like a few weeks or
even years in the future there's so much
fun you could play with that dynamic
however after the pilot it's rarely used
again my first criticism is that the
show offers nothing new to the zombie
genre a genre which has already been
flooded with hundreds of movies and
countless TV shows in order to stand out
from the rest you need to offer
something fresh and different black
summer doesn't do that it's generic
zombies generic deaths and a storyline
so simple get to the stadium that there
was not one thing in the show I hadn't
seen before stupid as stupid does miss I
know horror movies get [__] on a lot
when characters make stupid
decisions but black summer is just in a
league of its own
early on we know that aam bees are
attracted to sound and what does Lance
do over here bang a timpani what does he
do later on when he sees a zombie
instead of quietly walking in the
opposite direction he walks towards it
which almost gets him killed
just take a read of the current top
comment on IMDB know characters from
Mensa need apply the characters are all
single-digit IQs it seems the school did
it for me that's episode three I stopped
watching due to pure frustration at this
point
seriously how dumb do you need to be so
many levels of dumb the diner episode is
laughable the characters plan to kill
the zombie with a fire extinguisher it
totally backfires on them and a few
moments later Carmen is like do it again
it feels like these stupid decisions
were made by the writers in order to get
the characters in sticky situations like
to get chased by a zombie which comes
across as contrived and disingenuous and
is it just me or does no one except
Spears know how to shoot a zombie in the
head the characters in this show are so
damn unlikable part of what made the
first few seasons of The Walking Dead
both a critical and commercial success
was its ability to blend the zombie
genre with well-rounded character
development the first scene of The
Walking Dead is Rick literally deciding
whether to kill a child even though it's
a zombie black summer has completely
one-dimensional characters none of which
have character arcs flaws nor do we see
them change over the course of the
season this guy is just so pointless and
just walks away at the end the dialogue
is also pretty bad when the characters
aren't sitting around and waiting for
something to happen the dialogue is
largely expository or in the case of Sun
non-existent Early's non-existent in
English like I'm not even sure why they
made her character unable to understand
English it doesn't serve the plot at all
and it felt like the writers were just
like wouldn't it be cool if someone
didn't know English don't get me wrong I
think showing the perspective of someone
who can't communicate during this type
of crisis is interesting but they don't
go anywhere with it they don't explore
anything beyond the superficial and are
we all just gonna forget she had like a
minute long speech in Korean in episode
7 which no one
understands and there are no subtitles
and what about Velez over here I think
90% of his dialogue is him swearing and
yelling at other people to fight him
[Music]
seriously in their show about zombies
there's almost none of that classic
zombie ripping out intestines kind of
gore we've come to associate with
classics like Romero's Day of the Dead
Dawn of the Dead all that kind of stuff
even the Walking Dead goes leaps and
bounds beyond black summer in the way
they portray gore it's almost as if
every time we're about to see someone
attacked the camera moves away or the
editing cuts
show me how terrifying these creatures
are have them rip off a dude's arm while
they're still alive I'm here for black
summer not wet hot American summer
kidding I love that show there are just
so many little things that didn't make
sense for example when Rosa's husband
leaves the home he says the line it's
stinkin hot out yet if it's so hot
outside why is everyone wearing jackets
it's supposed to be summer right and
what about this whole storyline with the
military guys wanting Spears to take him
to his loot it's the end of the world
what good does money have no one really
questions how Spears and rose come back
with guns having killed the two military
guys Carmen does the stupidest move of
all stabbing the stood in the neck
jeopardizing their entire mission and
killing her boyfriend in the process and
there's just some overall laziness in
the production as well like in Episode
four when Lance is trying to restart the
car and his hand is all bloody but in
the next scene it's miraculously heal or
how you can see the camera guy in the
background or how if you're paying
attention to the background in the chase
episode they passed the same buildings
over and over again yes I was that bored
that I kept looking at the background
who the hell is this guy he just has
randomly like three people all tied up
this is a guy doing a lot more nefarious
[__] than just stealing some other
person's things also we never find out
what happened to Lance we literally
spend entire episodes with him and the
last shot we get of him is being chased
by zombies which leads me to my next
point
[Music]
talk about a lackluster ending
so basically Rose Spears and son finally
make it to the stadium where they've
been hoping to get to all along this is
especially significant for Rose who
believes her daughter will be there but
the stadium is M
the whole thing this series is building
up to was for nothing but out of the
blue appears her daughter now there is
the small chance this could be a
hallucination since we've seen Rose
experience those but I think it's
unlikely to top it off there's no tease
for next season no thread about where
the story will go from here
the characters are essentially in the
same exact position as when they started
the show none of them have changed and
nothing really has happened so what do
you guys think the black summer am I
totally wrong leaving your thoughts in
the comment below and make sure to LIKE
and subscribe also I have other take
down videos on night fliers and bum
houses new year new you so be sure to
check those out and if you want to
virtually harass me you can always do it
on good ol twitter at big story whitey
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much